nadège qu'en est il de la participation
et de l'atmosphère par rapport à cette
manifestation
bah écoute et grégory j'ai pas encore de
chiffres précis mais je peux vous dire
qu'ils sont plusieurs milliers de
personnes à s'être réunis ici place de
la résistance à paris pour dire non au
projet de loi bioéthique qui comprend
notamment la pma la procréation
médicalement assistée pour toutes les
fans un texte qui devrait être examiné
ce mardi par le sénat après avoir été
voté en première lecture par l'assemblée
nationale
tous les manifestants ici veulent que ce
texte soit rejetée par le sénat à
majorité de droite parmi ces
manifestants figurent jean frédéric
poisson un président du parti démocrate
chrétien
bonjour merci d'être avec nous alors
dites moi pourquoi est ce que vous avez
fait le déplacement pour quoi vous
participez cette manifestation parce que
dans la loi qui est étudié au sénat à
partir de mardi prochain
il y à tous les ferments d'une une forme
de destruction notre corps social quand
on bouleverse le lien des générations
quand on fabrique sciemment des enfants
qui n'auront pas de faire et qu'on le
sait qu on le fait de manière volontaire
quand on organise le marché de la
procréation et quand on soumet aux
forces de l'argent
d'une certaine manière ce qui était
réservé à l'amour et aux droits de la
vie jusqu'ici
eh bien on détruit deux manières pure et
simple
l'ensemble du corps social et cette
agression qui est commise contre la
famille contre les enfants contre la vie
est une chose extrêmement grave et c'est
pour ça qu'il est impératif que le sénat
rejette cette proposition doit et que
l'assemblée en fasse de même dans
quelques mois quand le texte se
retournera au palais bourbon
il ya des enfants qui sont malgré tout
malheureux même avec un papa ah oui bien
sur wii et pour moi qui suis issu d'une
famille des structures et je sais que
vous avez raison mais autre chose et de
d'être capable socialement de traiter
les accidents de la vie qui arrivent
partout et qui font des malheureux par
tout autre chose est effectivement
d'organiser une situation qui est
irrémédiable et ce n'est pas la même
chose que de perdre son papa pas à cause
de circonstances douloureuses que de
mettre chant et là il ya une volonté si
vous voulez de satisfaire des droits
illimité pour un certain nombre de
personnes en organisant la privation de
ses pairs de ses pairs pour les enfants
qui est quelque chose qui ne peut pas
correspondre à une organisation
harmonieuse de la société encore une
fois traitées les malheurs de la vie il
faut le faire nous le faisons organisé
ce malheur c'est quelque chose de plus
grave
est ce que vous avez à dire à ceux qui
disent qu'il faut vivre de vivre de son
époque vivre des bienfaits de la science
il ne peut pas être un bienfait de la
science que encore une fois d'organiser
de profiter de nouvelles techniques pour
priver les enfants de leur père ça c'est
pas un progrès le progrès de la science
ne consiste pas à mélanger du matériel à
nîmes animale et du matériel humain créé
ce qu'on appelle les chimères pour voir
ce que ça fait ça c'est pas un progrès
le progrès ne consiste pas à faire en
sorte que désormais c'est l'argent qui
décidera d'années sans dans sa tente
d'enfants et non pas la relation entre
les personnes et l'amour c'est pas non
plus un progrès personne n'est contre le
progrès et vivre avec son temps pour
bénéficier des progrès de la sens bien
sûr mais là ce ne sont pas des progrès
sont des régulations authentique parce
qu'elles font du mal aux personnes
laides et elles fragilisent la société
donc soutenir les progrès scientifiques
quand ils font du bonheur si j'ose dire
bien sûr tout le temps et tout le monde
y participe mais à clessé à ce point la
dignité humaine la cellule familiale
l'organisation sociale elle-même ça ne
peut pas être considéré comme un progrès
vous par ses clés le sénat va rejeter ce
texte vous êtes confiant et je doute
beaucoup parce que j'ai vu quelles
étaient les conclusions de la commission
spéciale vendu ces jours ci je constate
avec beaucoup de tristesse que cette
majorité des républicains au sénat a
produit un texte en commission qui est
beaucoup plus transgressifs que celui de
l'assemblée et je crains beaucoup que
effectivement le l'assemblée plénière de
confirmer le travail de la commission
maintenant rien n'est inéluctable il
reste encore les débats en séance
plénière et on sait qu'il peut se passer
beaucoup de choses donc je suis je suis
très inquiet mais
et tout est donc encore chine donc
j'espère que le scénar reviendra
résipiscence comme on déconne merci
beaucoup jean frédéric poisson je
rappelle que vous êtes président du
parti chrétien démocrate
merci beaucoup vous l'avez entendu
grégory un jean frédéric poisson comme
beaucoup d'autres ici
elle estime que ce texte de loi ce
projet de loi de bioéthique jean va
détruire la famille que quoi comme les
enfants ne
ne peut se passer d'un papa c'est ce que
ce ce qui l'est c'est ce qu'il a dit est
ce que pensent beaucoup d'autres
manifestants et 6 1 ce cortège il est
encore en place ici passionne la
résistance ils devraient partir didier
peut-être quelques minutes en direction
des 2
2 direction de la place de l'opéra en
fin de journée merci nadejda zakir
hossain donc de la manif pour tous
[Musique]